o Olá a todos pessoal daqui é que fala
dar que sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo pessoal e para quem é das antigas
para quem gosta de Dark frame a borrar a
cueca Dark frame jogos de terror hoje eu
não tenho aquele jogo Ok hoje eu trago
as aqui a melhor experiência de terror
que vocês podem ter online hoje em dia
ou menos foi assim que me venderam o
site só disseram Dark entra nesse site
que esse site aí Reis borrar a cueca vai
se assustar mete os Ou no máximo e ver
até ao fim então daqueles sites
lembram-se lá 2016 se não me engano fiz
um vídeo em que revelei o meu Facebook
ok para um é que supostamente wecker
entrou dentro do meu Facebook era uma
experiência assim meio assustador mas eu
vou deixar o link aqui na descrição se
não viram e os mesmos produtores fizeram
Outra experiência que não é que o
Facebook mas é que uma chamada de vídeo
ok eu vou entrar no site e eu vou estar
numa chamada de vídeo com pessoas
desconhecidas alguns no planeta né E vai
acontecer algo Paranormal Ok vamos ver o
quê
e foi isto que me explicaram aqui eu não
entrei vai ter Lollipop vem seu até o
fim comigo só coloquem os vossos fone
aumenta e o sono assim pessoal
fullscreen Se tiverem a verem PC e bora
lá como é que eu não vou chamar pessoal
como é que eu quero que as pessoas me
chamem aqui nessa experiência o eixo
Paulo estimulam agora vou ter que ativar
a minha é de quem é muito inclusive a
esta câmara que tem a ver agora OK vou
tentar ativar aqui ao mesmo tempo a
funcionar Ok não vem aqui algum tempo
mas o que está Conectar agora só uma
pergunta hello não Hello caminho que é
o ajuste
eu não tô com sono raiva é
E aí
e não é não vai morrer agora pode levar
entre pares pessoal vai dar susto agora
é
há 30 Sofia Sofia Dom te ligo nisso
Sofia vai medir 21st hang-on
G1
eu vou Sofia donde donde chorei tu não
tirei ainda está a ficar homem que lá
que isto é feito que eles da mãe que
está a ficar óleo Esse era o homem do
take my Lollipop vai dar susto agora vai
dar sugestão vou deixar sabia vai dar
susto então aqui ao PC
tu sabe onde eu moro tem a minha morada
ali
um caracolzinho Olha o outro homem
incrivelmente bem feito Pode Só faltou
eu para quem é quem
o meu Deus falou que a minha boca era eu
mas não era eu mexi eu fiz o teste eu
fiz assim olha eu eu não sou minha
câmera para falar eu Isto foi isto Foi
incrível entrei neste site por vossa
conta o dia que eu disse tudo tem o quê
funk do fantasma ele invadiu minha
cabeça está muito bem feito tá muito bem
feito só usar em outras experiências de
terror do Facebook eles sabiam a minha
formação de toda ok de qualquer forma
ele sabe onde eu moro pareceu-lhe a
morada com detalhe Ok sabe onde eu moro
né
Ah está bem mas mesmo assim assustador
aparecer ali tudo assim explícito net a
medo como é que essas pessoas que querem
informação pessoal eu quero perceber
como é que funcionou aquela última parte
meu vocês querem fazer outra vez a
experiência eu quero fazer outra vez meu
estava de fazer de novo ok vou tentar
entrar aqui só para ver se agora é
diferente eu vou tentar com outro nome
dela José qualquer coisa eu porque eu
quero perceber se aquela última parte eu
não fiz confusão Meu Whats tá muito bem
feito e vamos ver se tem outra variante
ou não se as pessoas mudam de vídeo olha
entrei no trem na sala vou escrever aqui
lá ai tudo bem É o mesmo vídeo é o mesmo
vídeo é cm ele vai dizer agora que eu
estou Hamilton pessoal não quiser e
postar um amigo vosso mandem Manda este
site para eles o site vai estar na
descrição OK aí o segundo a terceiro
link Aí eu saio eu mandei para os vossos
amigos e meus estudos estão muito para
mexer nele também lá correndo e
e eu mando uma foto para ela eu não
tenho muito cusão e até aquele homem
muito alto não é uma das coisas que mais
me assustei filmes de terror é tipo
pessoas muito altas muito magras muito
algumas aproximadamente altas estão
testemunha não sei se vocês já viram o
filme e ele falam mas não viram vejam
têm Monstros assim deste genero ok É
incrível e olha lá mas não é desligado
está preste oriano
e a você me fez o próximo ok ok ó
sozinho tá mexendo sozinho nessa mecha
mãe é Mary Kay se ele já está assustada
vai embora lá no chá de hibisco sempre
não pode ir embora ok ele não vai deixar
você ir embora e Imagina isso na vida
real tipo vocês entrarem dentro de um
site e no site acontecer coisas assim um
por um a cada pessoa no E meu isso era
muito disso tudo aqui dentro agora deu
para ver tinha alguém atrás dele 11
e agora ele vai aparecer atrás de mim né
aqui vai aparecer aqui ó Olá Olá olha
homens vai largar não quero eu não quero
eu não quero eu não quero
é algo Sofia sei que tu és o homem
porque Espera aí como é que cabe no
sistema cão ok pessoal agora bora
perceber a tirar o fone só para não
mostrar ok obrigado agora agora perceber
eu tô quieto Vou ficar só parado ó
é só quieto
o carácter perceber agora mesmo é
in my name is Alex ruas de freio ali pop
pesca nas ruas to play lollipop.com
chamamos escolheu um frame mesmo parecia
que eu estava a falar dois quer dizer
que não é chamado onde eu entrei já
tinha alguém com a maldição O que será
que era obviamente que foi regulado né
aquela que estava ao meu lado já me
esqueci do nome dela e o Mas enfim o
pessoal que não puderam vir uma
experiência incrível meu Espero que
tenham gostado aqui deste vídeo e se
quiserem vídeos a visitar sites
estranhos como este aqui começa em baixo
pessoal já sabem Deixei muito like aqui
neste vídeo Manda este site aos vossos
amigos a sustém os que estão à vontade
de vir tão pessoal eu não tenho certeza
se este site é sem por cento confiável
mas nunca deu problemas para mim o outro
vídeo do Lollipop também nunca deu
problemas portanto a partir de tudo
segura é tudo fidedigna OK mas partilhem
divirtam-se futebol e é isso fiquem bem
e até a próxima tchau
E aí
[Música]